um
no I had I there is an inexplicably
there's a box in my family's house full
of Genesis games no Genesis I have no
memories of playing Genesis I've never
played any of these games I don't know
who I don't know where this box came
this is a random box of Genesis games I
think I think it's
so my family dares not speak of or
something because
no one's explained it to me at all and
it's just it's not suspicious I got I
got I got a theory
and this is the cousin that nobody knows
argument over but which one was better
you got rid of them
secretly what happened is Chris raygon
got a a lost one brother he don't know
that was from the family
legitimate Child come on don't do that
somebody sent me somebody sent me a
picture